CASES FACEBOOK.
BRIT HUME IS WITH US NOW.
FOX NEWS SENIOR PARRILLO
ANALYST.
BRIT, WELCOME.
THE MESSAGING FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE WAS SUPPOSED TO BE ALL
DONALD TRUMP INACCURATE TRYING
TO SELL US THAT THE PANDEMIC WAS
OVER.
WE STILL GOT A MESSAGING PROBLEM
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE, DON'T WE?
>> WELL, WE DO WHEN HE IS TRYING
TO BLAME THE LACK OF FULL --
ENOUGH BEING VACCINATED ON
FACEBOOK.
FACEBOOK ISN'T RESPONSIBLE FOR
THAT FACEBOOK, IF ANYTHING, HAS
BEEN A HAND MAIDEN OF THE WHITE
HOUSE IN TRYING TO SUPPRESS
INFORMATION THAT FACEBOOK AND
THE WHITE HOUSE DON'T LIKE.
IT'S NOW BEING INVITED TO TOO SO
IN A MORE FORMAL WAY.
CERTAINLY NOT FAIR TO BLAME IT
ON FACEBOOK.
I THINK THAT THE MESSAGING FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE AND OTHER HEALTH
AUTHORITIES THROUGHOUT THIS
PANDEMIC, WHICH HAS TURNED OUT
TO BE EITHER WRONG OR LATER
CONTRADICTED AND SO ON
THROUGHOUT THIS WHOLE SEASON OF
THE PANDEMIC HAS LEFT PEOPLE
WONDERING WHAT THEY CAN TRULY
BELIEVE.
AND I THINK THAT IS RESPONSIBLE
IN LARGE MEASURE FOR THE FACT
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE STILL
RELUCTANT TO GET THE SHOT.
YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE PEOPLE THAT
DON'T LIKE SHOTS ANYWAY.
AND THEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE LIKE
ROBERT F. KENNEDY WHO ARE
ANTI-VAXERS OUT THERE WHO ARE
PROMOTING THIS INFORMATION.
BUT I THINK TRYING TO BLAME
FACEBOOK WAS A MISTAKE.
>> Brian: IT'S A DIRTY MISTAKE
DIRTY DOZEN GIVE US THE RANKINGS
AS IF WE ARE ALL SHEEP AND DON'T
MAKE OUR OWN DECISIONS LIKE IF
SENIORS DON'T KNOW THEY ARE
SENIORS OR PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMPROMISED DON'T KNOW THEY ARE
COMPROMISED.
I DIGRESS THE TEXAS LEGISLATORS
WHO CAME HERE AND LOOKED AT
THEMSELVES AS HEROES AND CHUCK
SCHUMER LOOKED OUT TO THEM TEARY
EYED FIND THEMSELVES OVERWHELMED
BY THE REALITY THAT THEY
IRRESPONSIBLY LEFT BOSTON WITH
NO BATTLE PLAN AND FIND
THEMSELVES THE SUBJECT OF BEING
COVID-19 POSITIVE NOT WARRIORS
FOR A CAUSE.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO HOW THEY
STEPPED ON THEIR MESSAGE?
>> Brit: WELL THIS WHOLE TRIP
HAS TURNED INTO A COMPLETE
FIASCO BECAUSE LEAVING THE
LEGISLATURE DOWN THERE AND
DEPRIVING IT ARE A QUORUM IS SCM
INTERFERING WITH THE DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS IN THE STATE OF TEXAS.
WHAT ARE THEY HERE TO PROTEST
ALLEGED INTERFERENCE DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS BECAUSE OF THE LAW ON
VOTING HOW IT'S TO BE CONDUCTED
THAT HAS BEEN PASSED BY THE
TEXAS HOUSE AND IS HEADED TEXAS
SENATE AND HEADED FOR THE TEXAS
HOUSE.
TO PROTEST INTERFERENCE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS THEY ARE,
GUESS WHAT?
INTERFERING IN A DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS AND THEN THEY FLY UP
HERE AND COME DOWN A BUNCH OF
THEM COME DOWN WITH COVID WHICH
IS EXTREMELY EMBARRASSING.
SOFT WHOLE TRIP, I THINK, IS A
TOTAL LOSS FOR THEM AS A
POLITICAL MATTER.
>> Brian: RIGHT.
SPEAKING OF TOTAL LOSS, EVERY
TIME THE VICE PRESIDENT TAKES ON
A MISSION, THEY SEEM TO BE
RAISING EYEBROWS.
FOR EXAMPLE HER LATEST MISSION
TO GET EVERYONE VACCINATED SHE
TAPPED INTO THE BIBLE.
LET'S LISTEN TOGETHER.
>> VERY ESSENCE OF WHAT THE
BIBLE TELLS US WHEN IT SAYS LOVE
THY NEIGHBOR.
AND IN THE FACE OF THAT STRANGER
YOU SEE A FRIEND.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
AND SO BY GETTING VACCINATED,
YOU ARE LOVING YOUR NEIGHBOR.
>> Brian: NOW I GET IT WHAT'S
YOUR REACTION TO REVEREND
HARRIS?
>> Brit: WELL, LOOK, IF YOU WANT
TO GET A SHOT, ON THE THEORY
THAT YOU WON'T BE LIKELY TO
CONTRACT THE DISEASE AND YOU
WILL BE UNLIKELY TO SPREAD IT
AND THAT'S AN ACT OF GENEROSITY
TOWARD YOUR NEIGHBOR, THERE IS
NOTHING WRONG WITH THAT.
IT SEEMS A LITTLE BIT OF A
STRETCH.
YOU KNOW, MY VIEW OF THAT IS
LOVE YOUR NEIGHBOR IS A GOOD
MESSAGE.
BRIAN, THERE IS SOMETHING I
WOULD LIKE TO MENTION HERE THAT
IS THAT ALL OF THIS DISCUSSION
NOW OF PEOPLE GETTING INFECTED
AFTER HAVING THE VACCINE IS A
LITTLE BIT -- IS A LITTLE BIT --
NEEDS A LITTLE BIT OF
PERSPECTIVE WHICH IS SIMPLY
THIS.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW SICK THESE
PEOPLE ARE WHO ARE GETTING IT WE
DON'T KNOW HOW GREAT OF A THREAT
IT IS.
WE HEAR 40% OF HOSPITALIZATIONS
IN BRITAIN ARE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
VACCINATED.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW SICK THEY ARE.
ABLE ALONG THE REASON FOR THE
EXTREME MEASURES THAT WERE
TAKEN, THE SHUTDOWNS.
THE CLOSING OF THE SCHOOLS.
THE CONSTANT WEARING OF THE
MASKS WHICH HAS DONE GREAT
COLLATERAL DAMAGE TO OUR COUNTRY
HAS BEEN ON THE PREMISE THAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH A DEADLY
DISEASE.
I THINK THAT THE PRESENCE OF THE
VACCINE AND THE FACT THAT A
GREAT MANY PEOPLE HAVE NATURAL
IMMUNITY OCCASIONED BY THE FACT
THAT THEY HAD THE VACCINE AND
SURVIVED IT HAS MEANT THAT THIS
THING IS SIMPLY NOT THE THREAT
IT ONCE WAS.
YOU KNOW, IT'S FUN TO TALK ABOUT
THE CASES AND HOW MANY THERE ARE
AND SO ON.
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS,
THAT THIS VIRUS NOW, BECAUSE OF
ALL THAT'S HAPPENED IS VERY MUCH
LESS DANGEROUS THAN IT USED TO
BE AND LET US PRAY, BRIAN, THAT
WE DON'T LAPSE BACK INTO
LOCKDOWNS AND UNIVERSAL MASKING
AND ALL THOSE THINGS THAT HAVE
BEEN SO DIFFICULT.
>> Brian: WE WILL BE TO BLAME
BECAUSE WE PUT IDIOTS IN CHARGE
AND THAT HAS PROVEN TO BE
COUNTER PRODUCTIVE.
THAT MEANS THEY DON'T LEARN FROM
ANY OF THEIR MISTAKE